California is one of 37 states that says
if a senator resigns or you know is no
longer in office during the rest of
their term
the governor gets to appoint their
replacement until the next election
Gavin Newsom
would be able to appoint the replacement
that replacement
is the one who would most likely go on
to obviously be the nominee for 2024
which could get rid of the need for the
primary
which means we wouldn't lose those
Democrats from the house now I know
that's a weird idea because it takes
away the primary it may not I mean if
they still want a primary they can still
primary they still have the option
but it kind of solidifies you know
listen
here's what we can do
so Gavin Newsom
needs to go meet with Dianne Feinstein